l'étendard monégasque flotte fièrement
sur le palais rainier iii de monaco
prend femmes la principauté est en état
d' alerte ses 200 policiers sont à pied
d'oeuvre et ses vingt mille habitants
attendent impatiemment la sortie du
cortège les cloches sonnent les canons
tirent des salves d'honneur
le marié et la mariée prononce le oui
traditionnel tous deux pas rester muet
non seigneur bart unis grace kelly au
dernier des grimaldi comme on l'appelait
habituellement
e
ans
comme dans les contes de fées monaco
aura désormais sa princesse
où
dans la bentley découverte le prince
rainier tiraille nerveusement son col et
la princesse le lui fait remarquer ce
qui a l'air de le mettre de bonne humeur
la bentley va faire un petit tour
d'honneur avant d'aller rejoindre les
750 habitée du l'ins déjà les jours ont
passé la princesse grace assure son rôle
et le prince a perdu son titre de
dernier des grimaldi après la princesse
caroline
il y à un héritier en la personne du
petit albert alexandre